[موسيقى]
برق جديد يلمع في فضاءات المدينه العربيه
كان قد غاب لقرون يمكن القول منذ نكبه ابن
رشد بحيث نلاحظ انعقاد مؤتمرات دوليه حول
معرفه كانت مغيبه في بلد وكان حضورها
خجولا في بلد اخر وكان حيره كبرى اعادت
رفاق المائده للجلوس والتفكر حتى بدا كان
هناك عوده للفلسفه واسئلتها القديمه
والمعاصره الى مدن وبلدان غابت عنها اويبت
لسنين
والملفت او المضيء انه اصبح للفلسفه داره
في الرياض وبيتا في الامارات في الفجيره
وبيوتا اخرى في مغرب البلاد ومشرقها وهذا
يشبه الاعلان او البيان عن البدء باعاده
ترميم غياب هذه المعرفه وترميم المعنى
الذي اصابه الضرر من جراء مصادرته من
تيارات الظلام
[موسيقى]
الفلسفه هي نبته اجتماعيه وان كانت طبعا
انشغالا ذاتيا وتراهن على الذاتيه وعلى
الاستقلال والحريه لكن هي ضمن هذا يعني
السياق الاجتماعي احد المؤرخين الفلسفه
يحاول ان يفسر ظهور لماذا تميز اليونان
بالفلسفه لماذا دائما يقال ان الفلسفه
بدات منه او علق انهم قدموا واحده من افضل
النسخ في التاريخ
بالضبط الدوله المدينه الدوله التي حققت
حققت شرط المدنيه شرط الامان وشرط
الاستقرار وشرط حتى الاستمتاع بالحياه
بالضبط كل الكلام كان على المائده نعم
فهذا هذه هذا الاسترخاء الوجودي الذي توفر
هذه المدنيه في الدوله المستقره في دوله
الرفاه يعطي هذا يعطي الانسان وقتا وفرصه
للتفكير
التفكير والتامل والمغامره
التقيت بهذا الشاب هنا في مدينه الفجيره
مشاركا في المؤتمر الذي ينظمه سنويا بيت
الفلسفه وكان من الطبيعي ان يفكر بصوت
عالاسباب التي ظهرت هذا الاهتمام بمعرفه
تعتبر عمود البيت المعرفي يتصحح الوصف
وبغيابها او تناسيها يتزعزع المعنى وتبدو
العلوم الانسانيه بكل فروعها في حاله من
التشوش تفقد قدرتها على قراءه العالم
والمجتمعات والحياه
ترى ما الذي دفع هؤلاء المثقفين والعاملين
في حقول الفكر والفلسفه الى طرح
سؤالها من جديد
اعتقد ان تحول
مؤخرا هو نوع من الاستجابه
لحاله حقيقيه داخل المجتمع يعني المجتمع
السعودي ومجتمعات اخرى مجاوره هناك
اهتمام
بالسؤال الفلسفي نتج عن اعتقد شخصيا انه
نتج عن القضايا الكبرى اللي مرت فيها
المنطقه يعني ابتداء من الاعمال الارهابيه
في 2003 تفجيرات اللي هزت الرياض القلق
الكبير القلق الوجودي اللي مر فيه المجتمع
اعتقد انه ولد في عقول كثير من شبابها
اتكلم عن الاجيال الجديده في ذلك الوقت
حركه فكريه هائله جدا كانت في السعوديه من
خلال الاسئله الناس تتساءل ما الذي يجري
وكيف يمكن تجاوزه وكيف يمكن حله فكان هناك
دائما رغبه في التعمق في
تجذير السؤال قدر الامكان هذا الحراك طبعا
انتج توجهات كثيره
واساليب كثيره في التعبير واحد منها كان
المنتج الفلسفي او التفكير الفلسفي
الجماعات التي اختارت ان تفكر من خلال
المنهجيه او الطريقه الفلسفيه لكن لم يكن
هناك مؤسسات
تستوعبها لم يكن هناك استجابه
من المؤسسات العامه لما تريده بظلك هذا
التحول الذي حدث في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه عبر التشريعات المختلفه عبر
الانفتاح على الحياه بكل تجلياتها على
الانفتاح على الاخر وعلى اسئله الاسئله
كان شبه مغيبه
هل هذا الانفتاح وتلك التشريعات هو الذي
سمح لاصوات كانت خافته في الماضي
للظهور للخروج الى الضوء اذا صح القول هذا
الانفتاح على مستوى التشريعي والمستوى
السياسي هو ايضا انعكاس الانفتاح اجتماعي
وحراك فكري عميق واسئله
مختلفه طرحتها شرائح المجتمع المختلفه
المجتمع السعودي اتوقع يعني النسبه
الغالبه فيهم من الشباب والشابات
وهؤلاء يتطلعون للمستقبل ويريدون ان
ياخذون هذه التجارب
ومن هذا التجارب الفكريه هناك مؤتمر مؤتمر
الفلسفه التي تنظم وزاره الثقافه العام
الماضي اجتمع نخبه فلاسفه العالم في
الرياض لمده ثلاثه ايام يتناقشون
ويتاملون ويفكرون الجميل او يمكن الاجمل
ان هناك حضن اجتماعي كان هناك شبان وشابات
كان هناك نقاش يعني المجتمع السعودي لم
يكن
متلقيا فقط لكن مشاركا ومتسائلا وتدخل في
حوارات معمقه مع هؤلاء الفلاسفه يعني انا
بعض الزملاء الفلاسفه من امريكا ومن كندا
كانوا ينشرون الى الطبيعه الاجتماعيه
للفلسفه بالسعوديه بمعنى يقولون نحن
اساتذه جامعات
ما المعتاد في المؤتمرات الفلسفيه هي انها
تكون للاساتذه ويحضرها في احسن الاحوال
الاساتذه والطلاب الجامعات خصوصا الدراسات
العليا لكن ما حدث في الرياض ان الحضور
كان متنوع جدا كان الاطباء يحضرون وكان
المهندسين يحضرون كان المختصين في
الفنانين يحضرون الشعراء يحضرون الادباء
يحضنونه كان الحضور من الاجيال مختلفه
لاني كانوا مهمومين بهذه صحيح سؤال اخر هو
انت وكسر من الزملاء يعني يفكرون الفلاسفه
مثقفون
لديكم الاسئله لديكم الهم هم اجتماعي هم
معرفي هم ثقافه
ولكن اريد ان اسال عن سقف الاسئله المتاحه
الان هل من محاذير حول اسئله معينه طبعا
اي انسان
ينتج معرفه يريد ان يقدمها للمجتمع بمعنى
ان يكون فاعلا في المجتمع وجزء من الحراك
الاجتماعي لابد ان يكون ضمن المعادله
الاجتماعيه يعني فهناك دائما محاذير
طبيعيه موجوده لكل مشتغل في اي شيء من
شؤون المعرفه
لكن اكثر من هذا لا يوجد يعني اكثر من هذا
هناك مساحه واسعه جدا اليوم من التساؤل
الفلسفي يعني هناك اسئله على الموروث او
بعض الموروث اللي اعاقه حركه الفكر هذا
متاح هذا متاح لكن يمكن اللي صار
مؤخرا انه لم يكن لم تعد هذه هي الوجهه
الوحيده يعني نعتقد ان المثقفين بشكل عام
نتيجه الضغط الاصولي جعلوا النقد
الاصوليات اولويه وهذا مفهوم لكن اذا
توفرت هناك بيئه
لا توجد في هذه الضغوط على المثقف قد يعود
المثقف مره اخرى الى الاسئله
الاكثر هدوءا احيانا ولكن هي اسئله جميله
هي اسئله فلسفيه اسئله مهمه اسئله تعكس
الشغف يعني احنا نراهن على الشغف الفلسفي
عند الانسان والذي قد يطرح احيانا اسئله
قد تبدو ساذجه قد تبدو
بديهيه لكنها هي هي لب هي الجوهر سبق لي
انت راحت هذا السؤال على بعض الاصدقاء في
المملكه وهو سؤال المملكه في عيون
مثقفيها وناسيها
السؤال هو انه لابد لابد من التقاء افكار
وطموحات المثقفين المتنورين مع افكار
وطموحات حاكم متنور هذا الالتقاء هو
الوحيد الذي يحدث تحول وهذا ما حدث على ما
اظن في المملكه كيف تقرا نعم هذه الفجوه
اللي كنا نشعر فيها فترات طويله يعني
اتكلم عن المثقفين بشكل عام اللي كان لا
يجدون صدى لافكارهم ولا يجدون ارتدادا
يعني
لماذا واحتضانا واي تفاعل هذا هذا الامر
تغير كثيرا يعني في السعوديه في السنوات
الاخيره اصبح القرار السياسي احيانا هو
يتقدم على على
افكار المثقفين وطروحاتهم
فعلا يعني قرارات حاسمه
اختصرت كثير من الوقت او من اعتقد حتى من
الالام
والصعوبات اللي كان ممكن المجتمع يمر فيها
حتى يصل الى هذه النتيجه تكلم لك مثلا على
المنظومه الحقوقيه يعني المنظومه الحقوقيه
فقط في الحقوق
الان تتمتع بها المراه
لولا هذه القرارات السياسيه الجريئه
والحاسمه
والعادله لكان كثير اجيال يمكن من النساء
واجهوا صعوبات يفترض ان لا يواجهوها فهذه
القرارات يعني على المستوى العدلي على
مستوى العدلي في السعوديه تشريعات كثيره
تتعلق بالحقوق والحريات تشريعات لتنظيم
العمل الثقافي وفتح المجالات احنا في
جمعيه الفلسفه عمرها سنتين لكن اقمنا
تقريبا انشطه بكل
كل مدن المملكه للاطفال للكبار لقضايا
مختلفه الامومه
الفيلسوف الصغير نعم عندنا برنامج اسمه
الفيلسوف الصغير هذا الفلسفه موجهه
للاطفال عندنا زملاء وزميلات متخصصين في
هذا المجال هل تعملون او تسعون لادخال
لادخال هذه الافكار هذه التصورات هذه
الاسئله الى المناهج التعليميه باعتبار
المناهج التعليميه بشكل عام هي الحجر
الاساس في تكوين الافراد وبالتالي تكوين
المجتمع
وبعلمك طبعا انه المناهج التعليميه
القديمه ربما هي التي اسست لهذه الحاله من
الجنود والسكو سنوات طوال نعم هنا هناك
خطوات يعني مثلا فيه مقرر اسمه التفكير
الناقد الان موجود في المدارس ايضا هناك
على مستوى الجامعات في دورات التدريبيه
لاعداد المعلمين في
تدريس هذه المقررات والعنايه بها حقيقه
يعني انا تربوي في الاصل
والتغيير في المؤسسه التربويه قد يكون هو
ابطا تغير في المجتمع هي اثقل
مؤسسه اجتماعيه
لكن لكن انا شخصيا لا زال لدي امل اكبر في
المؤسسه التربويه لازم تطمح ان يكون هناك
اقسام للفلسفه في الجامعات لم يعد من
مقبول ان تكون جامعات السعوديه لتنافس
اليوم وتاخذ حتى ترتيبات اعلى في مقاييس
الجامعات لا يوجد فيها اقسام فلسفه يفترض
هذه مطالبه انا اتمنى انه
رؤساء الجامعات والمسؤولين في الوزارات
التربويه يستجيبون لهذه المطالبه لم يعد
مقبولا ان تكون جامعات تقود يعني الخبره
التربويه والتعليميه في المنطقه ان تخلو
من هذا من هذا القسم الذي يعتبر قسم اساسي
في كل جامعات العالم الكبرى حتى مفهوم
الجامعه يعني
فلسفه صحيح وقسم الفلسفه بالعاده القسم
الفلسفه والمكتبه هي هي
القلب الذي يبنى حول كل بقايا الجسد
الجامعي
النهضه التي تحدث في السعوديه هي ليست فقط
نهضه اقتصاديه
الاقتصاد عصب في هذه النهضه واساسي جدا
لكنها لكنها نهضه انسان ونهضه ثقافيه
ونهضه فكر فلابد ان يكون هناك مؤسسات
تعتني بالخبره الروحيه الخبره الفكريه عند
الانسان
[موسيقى]
الخطاب الذي يعبر عنه الامير محمد بن
سلمان
بالنسبه للكثير من المثقفين وكانها يتحدث
باسمهم يعني
او كانه يعبر عن احلامهم او يعبر عن
طموحاتهم وهي احلام وطموحات زي ما تفضلت
انت هي مشروعه لكل انسان يعني في هذا
الوجود لكن جاءت الاراده
الشجاعه التي حولت هذه الاحلام الى الى
واقع ملموس
بالطبع هذا يعني ان المياه عادت الى النهر
بعد تجفيفه لسنوات
ويمكن القول ايضا ان الحياه عادت الى
الحياه بعد ايضا يعني بعد اختطاف لسنوات
طويله
وهناك كتاب جميل لسعيد السريحي بعنوان كي
لا نصحو مره اخرى او من جديد
وهو يطرح هذه المساله في الجوهر هل فكرتم
في هذا السؤال يعني او في الاسباب التي
ادت الى اختطاف المجتمع اذا صح القول
وسجنه لسنوات طوال نعم نعم هي يعني
خبرتنا مع الصحوه هي جزء من وعينا يعني من
وعي كل المثقفين المشتغلين بالفلسفه هي
تشغلنا حتى قد اعتقد ان تحولت ربما الى
اللاوعي لدينا ان ان كل ما شاهدنا حاله من
حالات الانفتاح كل ما شاهدنا مشهد من
اقبال الاجيال الجديده على الفكر الحر على
الفنون على
الاستمتاع بالحياه كاننا نتنفس
الاكسجين الذي حرمتنا منه الصحوه لفترات
طويله فنحن نعي بشكل عميق جدا
التحول الجذري الذي يحدث لكن ايضا انا
اشارك الدكتور سعيد
هذا القلق ان في الاخير لابد من تاسيس ولا
بد من تعميق لهذه التجربه ولابد من
تحويلها الى روح والتفكير والاسباب التي
ادت الى تمكن الصحوي من المجتمع
[موسيقى]
وبالطبع قد يفكر احدنا في سؤال كيف انتبه
هذا الجيل من الشباب الى عالم الفلسفه وهم
بشكل عام ينتمون الى بيئه مصادر فيها
السؤال الفلسفي كما هو معروف من التيارات
التي تدعي امتلاك الاجوبه والحقيقه عبد
الله المطيري واحد من هؤلاء الخليطين
الشكاكين والمهمومين على ما يبدو بسؤال
المعرفه والوجود لذلك ذهب مباشره الى
الفلسفه الى الفلسفه الوجوديه الى طرح
السؤال على كل ما هو جاهز او يدعي الجواب
المطلق والاخير هذا الهاجس المعرفي الذي
لديك او تلك الحيره تلك الاسئله التي
سكنتك مبكرا كيف تكونت هل هناك احد من
العائله يهتم
في العائله احد مهتم او عنده اشتغال مع في
هذه القضيه لكن
لكن يعني شخصيه امي وابي كانت
يعني شخصيه شخصيات تتصل بالوجود بطريقه
عميقه جدا وكان هناك حكمه حكمه معيشيه
الان انتبه لها يعني بعد هذا العمر
واتعملها سواء في اللغه ولا في الذكريات
ولا في الحديث فهذا يمكن الخبره الوجوديه
انت اشرت الى الفلسفه الوجوديه تعيدنا الى
تامل للانسان
في خبره اعمق من الخبره المعرفيه والفكريه
هناك ما هو اعمق الاتصال الوجودي بالكون
منذ الصغر انا كان لدي رغبه ان نجيب على
اسئله
كنت الكتابه كانت هي
هي
يعني هي الوسيله اللي من خلالها حاول انه
نجيب على هذه الاسئله لكني كلما كتبت كنت
اكتشف مقدار الجهل عندي وتتسع هذه الدائره
وكنت حقيقه يعني لدي رغبه عميقه في فهم
الخبره الانسانيه يعني هذا هذا اللي كان
يشغلني عشان كذا كان علاقتي مع الروائي
نجيب محفوظ علاقه عميقه جدا لانه هو
فيلسوف وجودي انا من وجهه نظري رواياتها
كلها نماذج للتامل الوجودي في الحياه وفي
الانسان هناك روح تسكنه كنت ابحث عنها
فعرفت ان انه درس البكالوريوس طبعا في
الفلسفه
فقلت ربما هذا هو
نجيب يعني نعم ما كانت دراسه فلسفه
المتاحه في السعوديه
لكن القراءه الكتب لحسن الحظ انها كانت
موجوده وكانوا الاس الكبار مثل ما اشرت
الدكتور سعيد السريحي الدكتور سعد البازعي
الدكتور معجب الزهراني كانوا هم هم
الاساتذه اللي كانت الفلسفه ايضا تمر من
خلالهم لنا ثم بعد ذلك حصلت الفرصه
نعم عند الابتعاد في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عن
واجه هذا الباب اللي باب قسم الفلسفه فكان
كان مقفل والان هو مفتوح والان امامي الان
مطلوب مني ان افتح الباب فاذكر اني التقيت
باحد الاساتذه
البريطانيا لكنه يدرس في امريكا
فقلت له انا اريد ان ادرس الفلسفه اريد ان
ادخل في برنامج الماجستير عندكم
فقال عندنا شرط نحن لابد ان يكون لديك 12
ساعه اكاديميه لكي تقبل يعني
فقلت انا عندي حكايه دعني احكيها لك وحكيت
لحكايه الفلسفه في السعوديه واشكالاتها
فقال لك علي ان انقل حكايتك هذا لاجتماع
مجلس القسم لكي نحصل لك على استثناء
لقبولك في القسم وفعلا هذا هذا الذي حدث
فكانت طبعا تجربه جميله في قسم الفلسفه في
جامعه فلوريدا ستيت
تحقق من خلالها الرغبه اللي انا كنت احرص
عليها
اذا كانت فرصه اتاحت لعبد الله المطيري ان
يدرس الفلسفه في جامعه فلوريدا ستيد في
امريكا ومع اساتذه كبار مختصين
ولا فيناس ونيتشي وحين اختار ان تكونوا
طروحته عن فلسفه الحوار حرفه الحظ مره
اخرى كما يقول بالفيلسوف مارتن كفك
المتخصص بسؤال الانا والاخر وبمنجز مارتن
بوبر فيلسوف الحوار الوجودي كما يعرف
وصاحب كتاب انا وانت وهذا ما جعله يتعمق
اكثر بدراسه فلسفه
المعروف بفيلسوف الضيافه والترحيب بالاخر
مما حفزه ايضا على التفكير ببحث في معنى
الضيافه عند العرب ووضع هذا السؤال في
مختبر الفلسفه
الاخر طبعا هو كانت اشكاليه كان يعني
العلاقه مع الاخر كانت اشكاليه من
اشكاليات
الازمه ازمه الصحوه لكن الذي حدث الان انا
اعيبه كثيرا ان الثقافه المحليه مثل مثل
الثقافه الشعوب الاخرى فيها عادات وتقاليد
تشهد او تعبر عن انفتاح
عالي على الاخر لا يوازيه اي انفتاح
وهذا اللي كنت احاول ان اكشف عنها في
الضيافه اطروحه الضيافه هذا الانسان
المضياف
انا وانت منتمي تقريبا لعادات متشابهه
ومتقاربه الناس
لماذا يقدسون الباب المفتوح لماذا يقدسون
لماذا يتوقفون عن سؤال الضيف عن اسمه
الا احترازا من ان يكون ان تكون هذه
الضيافه مشروطه بمن انت بهويتك وكانهم
يقولون سنرحب بك مهما كنت ايا كنت بل ان
الصح وحاولت ان تفسدها لانها تدخل فيها
المعايير الدينيه وهي وهي عادات تتجاوز كل
الاختلافات بين البشر الاختلافات العرقيه
والاختلافات الدينيه والاختلافات فالضيافه
انا يعني حاولت انه في هذا الكتاب ان
احللها طبعا مستخدما المنهج الفينيمولوجي
ظاهراتي ان احلل هذه العلاقه بين الذات هو
الاخر من خلال مشهد الضيافه الذي يكشف عن
انفتاح على الاخر
بدون شروط انكشاف مدهش ومذهل ويخرج
الانسان من من النمط الوجود اللي يمكن
تصوره او تعبير عنها بالوجود من اجل الذات
الى الوجود من اجل الاخر هذا انفتاح طبعا
الناس كان الضيافه للاجنبي وللغريب
وللمختلف والعبر السبيل لم تكن لمن يشبهنا
وهذا هذا هذا هو ما افسده وهذا ما يفسد
افسد لاحقا لكن هي الضيافه نفسها هي موقف
ترحيب واستقبال مخصص للاخر وليس للقريب
اهتمام النبيل ومعرفه النبيله هي الفلسفه
وغيابها يعني غياب المدينه بالمفهوم
الافلاطوني والدوله بالمفهوم الحديث امل
ان يضيء هذا التحول الدرب نحو مستقبل اجمل
واعدل ومدينه مطمئنه
[موسيقى]